あの順番で 今日は執着について お話しさせていただきます
要約にあったように
未練があると なかなか苦しいという話ですが
人間というのは いろんなものについて いろいろ未練があるんですよ
で 最初は 自分の親やらね
自分のおもちゃとかね
食べるものとか そういうところから 執着が始まります
で 一旦 子供にでも おもちゃあげたらね
それは喜んじゃったら
なかなか 手放しはしない
で 私たちも 子供を一応 騙しておくために
強引に 無意味なおもちゃなんかにね
ぬいぐるみなんかに執着させて
寝る時でも そばに置いておいて
時々それは病気になって
二十歳になっても ぬいぐるみがないと寝られない人もいます
女性はともかく 男の場合も結構ありますからね
で そこまで 勝手にどうでもいいんだけど
そこで危険な部分もあります
人間 死ぬ時も なかなか未練を捨てきれないで 死ぬんですよ
全ての未練 終わったと 無くなったというふうな状態で
清々しい気持ちで死ぬ人っていうのは めったにない
ほとんどない でもないんですよ
いるはずもないんです
で 未練があったら 今世で苦しむだけではなくて
問題っていうのは 死ぬ時もすごい いろんなことに未練があって
やり残したことがあって 死にますから
それから不幸になっちゃうんですね
一回死んだだけで
全てパーに無になるんだったら ありがたいんですけどね
物事っていうのは そうやって全く無になるっていうことは ないんですね
変化はあるんだけどね
今のあるものは 変化して違うものになるという
限りなく変化していく
だから消えた なくなった
もう終わったという 真空状態になるということは ありえないんです
ですから 心っていうのは しっかりしたエネルギーで
ものすごい巨大なパワーなんですよ
で 私たちはね 体を動かしたり
しゃべったりするのは 心のエネルギーなんですね
これぐらいの機械を作って 80年間 動かそうと思ったら どれぐらい大変かと
工学的に考えちゃうと 皆さんはわかるでしょうね
手を上げたり 下げたりすること
歩いたり 喋ったり 見たり
考えたりすることを 機械にやらせちゃうと
80年間は持ちませんね
いくら修理しても せいぜい10年で壊れてしまいますよ
ですから この物体を80年間
あるいはもっと長く
100年間でもね なんとか動かして起動させている
あの巨大なエネルギーが 心なんです
ですから 体をばかにしたとしても
心はばかにしてはいけません
みんなすごく軽々しく 心のエネルギーっていうのは 大したことないと思ってますけど
そうじゃないんです
大変なエネルギーなんです
想像を絶する力を持ってます
ただ汚れているんだから
我々にはそれがわからない
わからなくても 今の説明から見ると
体を機械に例えてみて 単なる物体として見て
この物体が ずっと80年以上ぐらいね
動いてるでしょう それはどちらの力かと
その年齢はどこから来るんですかと
それは純粋に 心の力なんですね
ですから 心というものも 瞬間 瞬間 変化する
体より早く変化する　体が変化するためには かなり時間がかかります
で 生まれた人間が 大人になるためには
一応 20年はかかります　子供の時だけは早く変わるんだけど
それからゆっくり 体っていうのは ゆっくり変わりますね
でも 心っていうのは ものすごく早く変わってしまうんですね
笑っている人を泣かせるために そんな時間はかかりません
ニコニコと笑っている人は 怒らせようと思ったらね
泣かせることは 難しいかもしれませんけど
怒らせることは 瞬時にできますね
ですから たった一日 会っただけでもね
今日 善人のようにいた人が
たった一日だけ 頭を変えれば
次の日は 殺人者にもなりかねません
それぐらい 心っていうのは ものすごい勢いで変化する
それもまた 巨大なエネルギーですね
その心が すごい未練があって
ものすごく重くて 死んじゃうと 先も ものすごく暗いんですよ
執着の一番の危険なところは
この 輪廻のことなんですね
ものすごい怖いところは
この世の中においては
もう なんとか頑張れますけど
執着があっても でもその時はすごいショックを受けちゃうんですよ
死にたくはないんです
で そろそろ死ぬんだな
死ぬんだなと思ったら
生まれて初めて すごい ひどい精神的なショックを受けて
怖くなって震えて
他の人にわからないんですよ
震えたくても 体が動かないんだから
死ぬ時だから それでさらにショックが強いんですよ
例えば 嫌だ 怖いんだとか言って 体を動かしたり
もういろいろなことをできれば
いくらかそこでエネルギーは発散しますよ
で もしかすると 体が麻痺状態になったりとかね
大体 死ぬ時はもう寝たきりで 何もできませんからね
その時は 心だけすごい恐怖感を 我慢しなくちゃいけないんですよ
ですから なかなか　これは危険であって
大変 危険というよりも ものすごく怖いことなんですね
お釈迦様がおっしゃるんですよ
人々にとっては ものすごい恐るべきことというのは
そういうことだと こんな遊んで生活したとしても
あまりにも乗り越えられないほどの 怖いことが待ってるんですよ
それは死ぬことではなく
死ぬ時の心なんですよ
そういうことだから 最初から執着っていうのは大変な
危険なものだと覚えておいた方が
いくらか未練が消えるだろうと思います
今日は執着している　何か知恵がないかという話ですから
執着のついてよりもね
そういうことだから やっぱり
大体 年取ってくると なかなか 自慢できるような生き方であるならば
死ぬ時は 何のことなく
自慢しながら死ねるんだったら
結構 執着というのは少ないんですよ
この 自慢という言葉はおかしい言葉でね
ちょっと気をつけないと
この 自慢というのは この
やっぱり 自分としては恥ずかしくないと
いろいろ いいことをしましたと
という 自分で 自分を褒められる状態なんですね
人に褒められることも あてにならないんですよ
人の褒め方っていうのは
ほとんど口先だけで褒める場合もあるし
あるいは誤解して 褒めるべきではないものも 褒める時あるしね
ですから 人に褒められることっていうのは
それほどあてにならない
人に褒められるんだったら
聖なる人々 智慧のある人々
ものすごい知識人が褒めるんだったら
それはいくらかあてになります
でも いつでも我々は知識人で 清らかな人々に 囲まれているわけじゃないんだからね
極普通の お互いによく知ってる人々に囲まれているんだから
あてにならないんですよ 褒めても
ですから 自分で自分のことを褒められるか という生き方
今日から始めると もう大丈夫だと
ということになるんですね 死ぬ時は
やることはないんだと
そういうふうな生き方をしておけば
かなり人間の 今世においても 人生は幸せになるし
で 死ぬ時も幸せに死ぬし
死んでからも 大変 幸せな生まれ変わりがあるんですね
心が重くなると どうしても下へ行くんでしょ
重いものはね これは物質と同じですね 働きが
心は物質ではありませんけど
やっぱりもう 下へ 下へ
低次元に 行くんですね
だから 例えば性格が悪い人とかね
余計な 悪いことばっかりする人々の人生を見ると
どんどん暗くなって 社会から離れて
暗くなって 不幸になって
影も薄くなって なんとなく いてもいなくても どうでもいいということになるでしょうね
例えば 犯罪する人々なんか
あなたは社会にいてほしくない という約束がありまして
追い出すでしょうね 社会から離れて別な場所に
刑務所というところに入れちゃう
入れて そこで人権 権利まで取り消す
人間としては扱わない
だからこの そういうことは我々に見えてますから
心は重くなると 上に行くということはないんですよ
執着によって 心は重くなっちゃいますね すごく
そういうことで 上に行くということは ありえないんですね
それは すごい厳密な論理的なことで
世の中を見てみるとね
やっぱり 欲深い人やら 怒り深い人やらね
で 成功するわけでもないしね
うまくいくわけでもないし
優しい人 自分のことをあんまりそんなに真剣に考えないで
みんなのことも 考える人とかね
どんどん軽く生きていて
上 上と行っちゃいますね
やはり死ぬ時でも その人は さらに上に行ってしまうんですよ
だから そういう論理なんですけど
なかなか 物に対する執着っていうのは 捨てきれないということは
我々の弱みなんですね
そこであの執着といえば
まず ものに対する執着
我々はいろんなものに囚われていますね
ものといえば 物質だけではなくて
人に対する執着も 同じことなんですね
ですから 人々っていうのは
家やら財産 家族 会社 そういう いろんなものに執着する
それはどういうことかと
よく反論で言うのは そういうものがなければ 生きていられないのではないかと
家族があったら幸せじゃないかと
お金があったら幸せではないかと
という反論するんですよ
で 仕事があった方が幸せじゃないんですかと
友達がいた方が幸せじゃないかと
だから何を言うんですかと
そこで 私は逆に反論したいんですよ
そんなこと わからないと思ってるんですかと
執着は良くないという人々は
それぐらいのこともわかってない
頭の悪いアホですかね
だからそんな単純なことを お釈迦様はわかってなかったんですかね
人間が土地があったら
そこで畑を耕して おいしくお腹いっぱい三食 食べてるんだと
家があると もう雨に触れないで
雪に触れないで 風から体を守っていることを お釈迦様は知らなかったんですかね
だから そんな反論っていうのはあまりにも 当てにならない反論なんですよ
そこで 一つの手段として言いたいのは
それは もう物事を知り尽くした人が 良くないと言うんだから
そちらに何かあるんじゃないかと
ただの誰かが言うんだったら
いい加減にしなさいと
例えば 勉強もしたことがないと
学校にも行ったことがないとか
人からものを乞うて食べている人とかね
性格も行儀も悪い いい加減な人が言うならばね
例えば 自分が人生失敗して ホームレスになっちゃって
そこで みんなに説教するんだったらね
そんな財産 会社なんかしちめんどくさいんですよと
私は全部やめましたよと
君らもやめなさいと言ったら
当てにする必要ないんですよ
私なんかは 小学校にも行ったことがないんだと
だからもう 別に勉強する必要は 何もないんだと
って言ったって それを当てにする必要ないんですよ
でも こういうことをおっしゃっているのはお釈迦様ですからね
人生の失敗者ではなかったんだからね
そういうことだから
何か大事な意味があるんだと
ということを覚えておいた方が
まだ実践しやすいと思います
で そこで ものに対する執着
それは どのような働きがありますかというと
私が何か欲しいと思ったら
それから苦労して その欲しがるものを 得なくちゃいけないんですよ
で 得たとしても じゃあ自分が希望するような感じで
希望したような通りに そのものから幸せを得られますか？っていう
それから得たものも どんどん変化しているんだからね
例えば 服を買っても 高いお金で
2 3回着たら もう使えなくなるぐらいの 高ければ高いほど そういうことなんですね
1,000円  2,000円で買ったものは
洗っても2 3年は着られますけどね
10万  20万のものは そうはいかないんです
ですから この それはすぐ消えてしまうんですよ
そうするとすごく悔しいんですね
もう一つ大事なポイントは
それでもなくて もう一つ大事なポイントがあるんですね
私たちは自分の幸せは 物にありと
お金にあると 家にあると思っているんですよ
結婚したら私は幸せですよというと
自分の幸せは 結婚にあるんですよ
家族がいたら私が幸せですよと思ったら
家族にあるんですね 幸せが
ものが 自分の幸せを作ってくれなくてはいけない状態に なってしまうのです
それで 自由に動けなくなってしまうのですね
私たちの自由はなくなってしまうのですね　それっきり
ものすごく 厳密に束縛されるんですよ
で 会社が命だ 家族が命だとか 何とかとか思ったらね
その人には 1 秒でも自由がなくなってしまうんです
結局 自分が奴隷になるんですよ
ものの奴隷になる なぜならば
そのものが 自分に幸せを作ってくれるんだから
そこで幸せというのは
ちょっとした喜びぐらいのものなんですけど
楽しいというぐらいのことですけど
お金があれば幸せという人は お金の奴隷になる
お金が神様になってしまって
で 神様が自分に幸せを与えてくれる
ですから 自分の言う通りに お金が動くんじゃなくて
お金が言う通りに 自分が動かなくちゃいけないんですよ
例えば 金儲けたいと思ったら
お金にもそれなりの法則があるでしょ
私たちは 自分が金欲しければ
そのお金の法則に従って生活しなくちゃいけない
自分好き勝手にお金入ってこいと言っても 入ってこないんだからね
お金 どんどん入ってこいと言っても 入ってこない
それなりの行動をしなくちゃいけない
自分が結婚したいと思ったとしても
すぐ瞬時に世の中のね
適切な人が 飛んでくるわけじゃないんです
自分が一生懸命 探さなくちゃいけないんですね
探したところで 向こうは行ってあげるという状態だからね
こちらが 向こうの条件をのまなくちゃいけないんですよ
お金の場合も同じなんですよ
じゃあ あなたのところに行ってあげると
ですから お金の条件を飲み込まなくちゃいけないんですね
大きな家を建てたらどうなるんですかね
家が自分の条件を持ってますよ
一旦 家に住み始めたら
家が言う通りに 私たちは生活しなくちゃいけないんですよ
私たちが言う通りに 家が変化することはないんですね
だから 執着っていうのは
簡単に人が何もできない 完璧な奴隷にすることなんです
そこで 自分というものは消えてしまうんですよ 結局は
自分がただ 社会に振り回されている道具に過ぎないんですよ
そこで 心の中でものすごい 葛藤が生まれるんですね
やっぱり自分がいるんだと
自分の意思でも何かやりたいと
という気持ちがずっとあるんですよ
でも それも 一度も味わうことはできなくなっちゃうんですね
お釈迦様の時代ではなくて
ジャータカ物語に 執着について ある物語があるんです
昔々 これ物語ですけどね
ある人が 家も迷惑だと
財産も迷惑ですと 心は汚れるんだと
心清らかにする人にとっては
もうそういうものは迷惑ですと思って
すべて捨てて 森の中に入る
インドの話だから このヒマラヤに入ると
Himavantaṃ pabbataṃ pavisitvā というふうになってますからヒマラヤに入っちゃうんですね
そこで 一つだけ持っていくんですよ
全て捨てても 腰にちょっと布一切れをね
今の寸法で言えば
もしかすると１メートルぐらい
ちょっとした一切れを持って
それを腰に巻いて ちょっと この恥ずかしいところを隠すだけ
上は何も着ていない 草履も履いていない
ただそれだけ持って 山の中に入る
それで一生懸命修行するんですよ
で そこで 自分であちこちから葉っぱやら枝やら 拾ってきて
ちょっとあの 小さなね
住むところを作って 生活しているんだけど
夜寝て ある日 夜寝て起きてみたら
布一切れを 噛まれているんですね
次の日また 見たらもっと噛まれているんですよ
誰かと 何でしょうかと思ったら
ネズミがいるんです
ネズミがその部屋に入り込んじゃって
布を噛むんですね この人 こう思った
これ大変だと 私にこの布一切れしかないんだからね
これなくなったら 裸でいることになっちゃいますよと
どうしよう ネズミを追い出さなくちゃいけない
これ なかなか見つかりませんね
それで考えたのは ネズミはやっぱり猫が怖いんですね
そこでまた一旦 山を下りて村に行って
猫を１匹 拾ってきたんですよ
で 拾ってきたら 猫を連れて山に入ったところで
ネズミは怖くなっちゃったんだけど
でも猫は１日 ２日いて 面白くないんですね
食べるものもない この人はもう果物やらね
そういう山にあるものを食べるんだけどね
なかなかバナナ食べる猫とかいないんだからね
だから一旦 出家してるんだから
もう修行者だからね 自分でいろいろ取ってあげることもできないし
狩りをして　だから猫が自分で餌を探さなくちゃいけないんだから
なかなか いないんですね
なかなか それで困ったと
猫がいなくなっちゃったら ネズミが来るんじゃないかと
それで考えたのは 餌さえあれば お腹さえね
満腹にしておけば 猫はグーグーと寝ているでしょうと思って
猫に餌をあげなくてはならないことになりました
それで彼が また村に入って托鉢をする
牛乳とかね
そういうのを作っているところに托鉢に行ったら
あるものをあげるんだから
牛乳とかね そういうものをもらったりする
で そういう適当に 猫が食べるものがあるところに托鉢に行ったら
そういうものをもらう
で もらったりするんだけど
そこで帰ってきて １日なくなっちゃうんですよ
それで考えたのは 修行の時間がなくなったんだ
自分で牛一頭 もらってくればいいんじゃないかっていうことで
これは仏教以前のバラモン文化の話だから
そういうものをもらうのは簡単ですね
そこで牛一頭もらってきて
で 山で牛に餌を食べさせて
牛乳を取って猫にあげる
牛の面倒を見なくちゃいけないんですね これから
それでその人が考えたのは
これ自分の修行に来たんだからね
牛の面倒に一日かかっちゃうと困ると 言って
村からお手伝いするために男の子を一人 連れてくるんです
で その子に 君がこの牛の面倒を見なさいと
その代わりに その人は行って托鉢して
二人分 托鉢してくるんです
結構 時間かかって 男の人は牛の面倒を見る
でも男の人っていうのは面白くないんだから
森の中にいるのは
あっちこっち村に行ったりする 遊びに
で なかなか帰らなかったりとかね
そこで考えたのは この子はもう若者ですし
今はね ですから 相手がいれば
あっちこっち行かないでいるだろうと思って
お嫁さんも連れてくるんですよ
そういうふうに どんどん
結局 その人の人生は 台無しになっちゃったんです
みんなの面倒を見なくちゃいけないでしょう
結局 自分が捨てた世界にまた戻って
また大変 苦しい世界になってしまったと
そのストーリーを言って
どこで間違ってるんでしょうかと
考え方ですよ　あの布一切れに対する執着なんです
これは私のもの これはなくなったらもう大変だと
守らなくちゃいけないんだと
たったそれだけの考え方で
せっかく山に入った 家出して出家した人が すべてなくなって
結局 還俗することになっちゃったんです
こんなこと言ったって切りがない
一応また戻って 普通にお仕事をして
みんなを養うんだということに 元に戻ってしまったんですね
だから 聖なる道を歩むことはできなかったんです
そういうことで 執着にはそういうからくりがあるんです
だから 誰にでも これは出家の場合だけではなくて
物に囚われたら もうどんどん不幸が増えるんであって
幸福が増えるわけじゃないんです
その幸福が増えるということは
ちょっとした錯覚なんですよ
お母さんたちがよく知ってるでしょ
すごい気持ちよく結婚するでしょう
最高の幸せだと思って
その日からどうですかね
人生は  1日も休みがないでしょうに
そこで子供育てて大きくなったところで
子供を結婚させたところで
じゃあ休めるかというと
それで孫が出てくるんですよ
自分の子供のことが心配で
（子供には）孫の子育てできないだろうと思って
孫に手を焼くようになっちゃうんです
で それもなんとか手放すことになっちゃうと
自分がもう動けなくなっちゃって
それで他の人々は もう死ぬまで留守番頼んじゃうんです
みんなあっちこち出かけているんだけど
もう年取ってるおばあちゃんには
じゃあ おばあちゃん留守番お願いしますと
だから 現代女性はいくらかは自由なんですけど
一般的に言えば 一生家に束縛されて 家の奴隷になるんでしょう
避ける方法はないんですよ
で 男性にしても同じく 自由はないんです
自由をなぜ失うかというと
ものに囚われているからなんです
そこで問題は じゃあ全部捨ててしまえばいいか ということでしょうかね
ある人が全部捨てたんだからね
あのストーリーに出てくる人が　全部捨てたんだけど
問題は解決しなかったんです
あのストーリーは 作ったストーリーかもしれませんけど
厳密に 心理学的に考えて作っているストーリーなんですよ
あのバラモン人が全財産 捨てて 山に入ったんです
本当に正直な気持ちで
禅定をつくって 梵天に生まれ変わりたいんだという
インチキではなかったんです
でも問題は 彼は物を捨てたんだけど
執着を捨てなかったんですよ
彼が捨てるべきものは捨てないで
捨ててもどうでもいいことは 捨てちゃったんです
例えば 執着が良くないんだからと 自分の子供を捨てるんだと
コインコインロッカーに入れて逃げちゃうんだと
それで執着は消えますかね
消えません　一生あの苦しみは追ってくるんです
自分が子供を捨てたんだと
だから 邪険になって いい加減に物を捨てても
それは間違ってます
あのバラモン人が何を捨てるべきですかというと
物に対する執着なんですよ
物ではなかったんです
例えば子供に執着する
何の意味もないんですよ
じゃあ執着しない だから子供を捨てますよと
それも間違いですよ どうせ子供っていうのは 捨てなくても出て行っちゃいますよ
だから執着さえ捨てれば
子供を捨てる必要はないんです
面倒は見るんだけど 育ててはあげるんだけど
執着はないんだと 出て行ったならば
出て行ったか まあ終わりと
それで割り切っちゃえばいいんです
そう割り切れないでしょうね
子供は独立しようと思ったら 頑固に反対するでしょうに
それで苦しみが生まれてくる
例えば よく子育ての問題についてね
いろいろ話を聞かされますが
問題はいつでも 私は聞いたところで
母親の 限りない無知と執着にあるんですよ
よくよく話を聞くと 別にそんなに大胆な問題じゃないんです
ごくありふれた どこにでもある
どんな子供でもやる 同じことなんですよ
どんなこともね 学校に行きたくないとかね
あの学校の連中 嫌だとかね
先生なんかは嫌いですよとかね
そんなことは しょっちゅう言うでしょうね
でも この執着ある母親にとっては
それは我慢できなくなるんですよ
それで間違った態度を取る
結果として 子供は間違った行動をする
それで二人とも不幸になる
で それもう一つは お釈迦様の経典から一つ
引用はいたしませんけど
あまりものすごい長い経典の
テーマ ポイントだけ説明します
お釈迦様がこの 世間から離れて
欲から離れて 心を清らかにする
出家者は 比丘はどのようにするべきか ということのポイントの経典で
例えば 人が村で 町で生活する人というのは 出家者ですね
村で 町で生活すると大変 面倒くさいんだと
うるさいし いろんなものがあるんだから 欲が生まれてくるし
修行にはなりませんと思って
人の声も聞こえない森に入るんだと
宗教の世界で この森に入って 山に入って修行することは
えらいありがたいと思っていますよ
仏教の世界でも アランニャ(arañña)というのは森のことで
もうテーラワーダの世界でもアランニャ派といって
宗派まであるんですね
我々は出家して アランニャに生活しているんだと
他のお坊さんたちは 町で生活しているので
それに対立して 自分たちがアランニャ派で
まあリンジン派ですか 森林派というんですね 日本語で
そういうことを 本当にお釈迦様はすごいと思っているかと
そこでお釈迦様は 経でこう言うんですよ
もしある修行者が森に入ったとする
森の中で生活していると
なかった煩悩が生まれるならば
ある煩悩もどんどん成長するならば
その森の生活はやめた方がいいと
ただ単に形だけで森にいても 意味がないということなんですね
例えば 森に入ったとする
いきなり寂しくなるかもしれません
人の顔を見られませんし
一言もしゃべる相手もいないし
寂しくなる可能性あります
それでまるっきり一人でいると
すごい大変なことなんですよ
皆さんもちょっと 味わってみた方がいいんですよ
1日 2日間ぐらい誰とも喋らないで
テレビも見ないで 新聞も見ないで生活してみてください
これはどれくらい大変なことかと
で そうやって森の中に入ったら
その人にとってはもう夜なんかはね
いろんなことを思い浮かぶでしょうね
家にいた時は この時間になってくると 子供は遊んでいるんだとかね
で 家の自分の奥さんも いろいろ料理作ったり
いろんなことしたり いるでしょうとかね
寝るときは一緒に 子供が自分のところに入り込んできて
一緒に寝るでしょうとかね
朝になってくると 家にいたのだったらね
朝だったら起きて あっち行ったり こっち行ったりするんではないかとかね
そういうことを思い浮かんじゃうとどうなるんですかね
どんどん欲が増えてくるんですよ
精神的にショック 受けちゃうんですよ
であるならば 山を下りろと
意味がないんだと その修行の
じゃあ 村に生活する出家者はどうですかと
もし村に生活すると 女性の方々やら
すごい豊かな人々やら
すごいごちそうを食べている人々やら
お祭りやったり ものすごい元気で遊んだり
人々やら見ると 悔しくてたまらないと
やっぱり惜しいなとかね
昔だったら自分もね そういうふうに遊んだのにとかね
思ったりしちゃうと 自分の出家が嫌になってくるんですよ
そういう人だったら 村で生活してはいけないと
だからお釈迦様の出家っていうのは
この森林派とか そういう宗派に分けたわけじゃなくて
物を捨てる やり方ではなくて
心にある執着を捨てる やり方なんです
だから 全く都会で生活しながらも 悟りを開いた人々がいるし
都会でまるっきりダメで
村に入って 人が少ないところで修行して 悟った人々もいましたし
それもダメで 山の中に入って 森に入って 修行した人々もいましたし
だから 捨てる教え なんですけど
捨てるのは 物ではありません
物に対する執着
スッタニパータというテキストに出てくる言葉なんですが
ある哲学者というか 宗教思想家なんですけど
彼がこの偈で 歌で こう言うんですね
この カーマ(kāma) 欲というのは
この世の中である美しいもの
全部 カーマ 欲ですよと
なんか当たってるような気がするでしょ
世の中に美しいものは いっぱいあるでしょうね
いわゆる 心が惹かれるもの
今も言ったような 財産やら美しい人々やら
仲のいい友達やら
いろんなものがありますね
楽しいものいっぱい そういう楽しいものが欲であると
だってそういうものをやっちゃうと
心にどんどん 欲が生まれてくるんだから
そういう欲であると言ったら
仏教の答えは この世の中にある美しいものは 欲ではありません 一つも
綺麗な人々も お祭りもパーティーも欲じゃないんだ そんなことは
もう家族も なんだかんだ
そういうのは欲ではありません
欲っていうのは 心の中にある その感情ですよ
ですから 現代日本語で言えば
花を見たら はあ きれいだ
欲しいなと思っちゃうでしょう
悪いのは花ではないんですよ
こいつは悪いんだと 私の心に欲を作ったんだと
例えば 若い男性の人が すごい綺麗な人を見る
美人を見る 見たらいきなり 心の中で欲が生まれてくる
そうすると やっぱり美人が悪いんだと
心に欲が生まれたんだから と思うのは 間違いなんですよ
悪いのは自分なんです
パーリ語で言えば saṅkapparāgo purisassa kāmo
saṅkapparāgo ものについて妄想する
考えること自体が欲であると
例えば 花を見たら花ですと終わっちゃえば
そこで欲は生まれません
これは何の花ですか？どんな色ですか
ああ 欲しいですね これは自分の家に持ってきて
玄関かこういうところに 花瓶に挿しておけば
やっぱりさすが綺麗でしょうとかね
あるいは植えている花を見ていたら
やっぱり自分の家でもね
玄関のところに こんな感じの花を植えておけば
やっぱり綺麗でしょうとか
そういうふうに 妄想を働かすことによって 欲が生まれてくるんです
執着が生まれてくるんです
だから 物が悪くはないんです
だから やけになって物を投げ捨てたとしても
それは仏教的な道ではありません
そこは全 くインドでは 何かよくあるみたいなんですよ
この NHK の 昔
いくつかの番組を見たんだけども
修行に行かなくちゃいけないとかね
修行といったって あれは何といいますか
巡礼に行かなくちゃいけないとか
そういうくだらん話を作ってしまって
もう長い間  2 3 年からも　そこで平気で結婚して
家族もいるのに 平気でこの男の人たちが いきなり巡礼に行く
インド文化では 巡礼に行くときはお金が要りません
ただ出て行けばいいんです
巡礼者だから みんな食べるものやら着るものやら
もう 寄付するんですよ
でお金もくれるんですよ
それで 人からご飯をもらうわ
寝るところももらうし
必要なお金もちょっともらうし
ご飯ない場合は それで買って食べればよろしいし
それで あっちこっち あの山この山とかね
回っちゃうんです 家族はどうなるんですかと
それで NHK 取材で出したのは
この 14歳の 12 4歳かな
男の子を何人か撮っていたんだけど
家になんか兄弟4人ぐらいいて
その小さな子は 学校にも行かないで
いろんなものを駅で 水やら何とかを売って
ほんのちょっとお金儲けて
またそれで材料を買って 夜 家に入って
もう 14歳の男の子なんですよ
自分の妹たちに料理を作って食べさせる
なんて残酷な生き方かと
それでその子供に聞いたのは
あなた学校なんかに行きたくないんですかと
学校に行って勉強したいんだと
でも妹たちが 3人いるんだから
もう学校にも行けないんだと
お金もないんだと でお父さん
お父さんは巡礼に行っているんだと
何日で帰ります？わかりませんと
もう何年も帰りませんと
一回帰って また 2 3週間で出て行ったんだと
自分一人 勝手に聖者ぶりをやったりして
あれぐらい家族を不幸にする道っていうのは
それはもう どう見ても認めたくない
認めるわけにはいかないでしょう
そういう無責任な生き方ではなくて
これは心の問題なんですね
煩悩というものも 執着というものも
ああいうのは無責任な 責任逃れというか
夜逃げというか いい加減というか
わがままというかね それで心清らかになると思ったら
これ大違いですよ よく言うことは
お釈迦様も 自分の奥さんと息子を置いて 出家したのではないかと
みんな忘れることは お釈迦様は貧しい人でしたかね
えらい豊かな人で あまりにも贅沢
想像を絶する 贅沢な生き方をした人でしょう
釈迦族の王になる人で 一人息子でしたしね スッドーダナ国王の
でお釈迦様が考えたのは そういう考え方じゃないんですよ
みんな自分に期待しているんだと
希望の星が生まれたんだと
あまりにも ものすごい頭が良くて 天才で
それはもう釈迦族も 巨大な国にしてくれるだろうと
だから大体 伝説の話を見れば
全... 国王と言っても
昔は恐らく すべての世界というのは
おそらくインドぐらいのことだと思いますけど
すべての国々を治めるんだと
チャッカヴァッティ(Cakkavatti 転輪聖王)という名前の王になるんだと
それは英訳すると universal monarch と訳するんだけど
全宇宙ユニバースの王にはなりっこはないんだけど
まあ当時そのストーリーを作った人々はね
インド以外国々あったかどうか
もうそれはちょっとわかりませんが
とにかく インドぐらいでも 治めるでしょうということかもしれません
あれぐらい能力あれば できないわけでもないし
今もお釈迦様は 世間ね
かなりの方のコントロールしているんだから
もう最近 崩れたんだけど
前はね 世界で一番大きい人口は仏教徒でしたから
ですから それぐらい能力があったんだから
希望の星でしたから お釈迦様は真面目に考えたんですよ
こんな ご飯食べて
単なるみんなの日常生活のことに ちょっと愚痴を出したりぐらいでね
この人生の問題は解決できませんと
ということで 家を出たんであって
無責任で 私が亡くなったら
この奥さんには食べるものなくなるんだとかね
この子供にも誰が面倒見るんですかとか
それはいたとしても面倒見ないんですよ
在家でいても そちらには召使いやら いろいろ家来がいるんだから
ですから お釈迦様の出家っていうのは
いい加減に無責任で出たことではなくて
それは 豊かな人がもう
みんなのために出て行ったことで
そういうことで ただ無責任に ものを捨てるということは
決して執着を捨てることにはなりません
それはかえって 怒りか
あるいは自分の弱み 責任を果たせない
だから言い訳して逃げる
現代社会ではね もう世界でよくありますよ
そういう宗教に興味あるという
瞑想に興味あると あっちこち地球上を回っているんですよ
あ これは新しい時代だとか言ってますが
私はそんな もういい加減だと
おかしいんだと そういう歩き回っている人々が ほとんどものにならない
あの国に行って 2 3週間
1ヶ月とか なんとかやって
次の国に行って 2 3ヶ月間そちらに行って
で 威張るんです 私はネパールに行って瞑想したんだ
インドのリシケシに行って瞑想したんだ
ミャンマーにも行ったんだ
タイにも行ったんだとかね
それからフランスにも なんとかの道場に入って
そちらの修行もしてみたんだとかね
結局 聞きたいのは あなた何を得たんですかというと
ただのアホですからね
何も知らないだけで 終わっちゃうんですよ
だからこの 現代社会でも
そういう精神世界に興味あるという人々いるんだけど
よく見るとただの失敗作なんですよ 社会の
仕事をしたくない
あるいは親とうまくいかない
あるいは西洋人だったらすっごい激しい競争的な社会だから
何か怖くなって 腰抜けて逃げちゃうんですよ
そこで東洋の神秘を目指して
ものにならないんですよ
それでものになる西洋人もいますけど
それはもうちゃんと大学 college を卒業して
まあ いくらか仕事をしてみて
本当に知識的にやっぱり興味が出てきて
やっぱりこれ知らなきゃ
西洋の文化っていうのは もう知り尽くしたと
そんなにあまり意味がないんだと
いって どこかに行って真面目に勉強したり
真面目に修行したりする場合は
もう本当に 立派で役に立ちますけど
世俗的な生き方を失敗する人は 出家も失敗するんですよ
心が悪いんだから 考え方がおかしいんだから
だから逃げただけで 何も問題解決しません
だから そこら辺ですね
我々はちょっと混乱しているのは
ただものを捨てた それでしっかりしたわけじゃないんですね
やっぱり成功する人が 成功できるような思考を働いている人が
在家であろうとも成功する
出家であろうとも成功する
そこで勘違いして欲しくない
在家で成功っていうのは 豊かになることなんですけど
出家で成功することは すごい金持ちになることじゃないんです
それは精神的な世界で成功する
それは日本でよく勘違いしているんです
宗教を一つ作って
会社を二つ 三つ作ったよりも 金持ちになってやるぞと
それはもう えらい勘違いで
だから宗教の世界に入る方々いるでしょうに
次に 宮殿のような建物をあっちこっちに作って
王様のごとく生活する
みんなからお金をだまし取って
だから在家でお金だましちゃったら
もう行く先が決まってるんだから
そこで出家という 出家じゃなくて
宗教を装って
人を騙すのと同じ　もう騙し屋なんですよ
そういうものに 我々はすぐ かえって騙されちゃいます
見抜くことはできないんですね
だから お釈迦様の智慧があれば
それは 簡単に見抜くことはできるんですよ
だから 物事をしっかり考え
例えば バラモンの あの行者のストーリーから考えると
その人が 別に心を清らかにしたければ
家ででも できたはずなんですよ
家ででも 無執着の生活をできたはずなんです
それを もののせいだと思ったんですね
自分の心が汚れるの
腰に巻くだけの布 一枚持って行ったんだけど
結局 元の生活に戻るようになってしまったんです
だから インチキ生活になってしまったんですね
で そういう働きなんですから
仏教でいうこの 執着っていうのは
一つの心の状態　物事をわかってない状態なんですよ
だから 高級なブランドのものがあったら幸せだと思っちゃうと
頭がおかしい　頭が病気
そういうふうに思った方が
フランス製 イタリア製のカバンがあれば
自分が幸せだと それぐらい自分の心はくだらないものですかね
2  3年でボロボロになるものに任すんですかね
自分の心の幸せっていうのは
だから その思考 自体がおかしいんですね
ものにとらわれると
だからといって そんなものを使うなよという話じゃないんです
そんなに カバンでもって かけてるメガネのブランドでもって 着ている服でもって
自分を偉いと見せかけることは いかにおかしいかと　それだけなんですよ
人格者は ブランドの品物を身に着けてあってもなくても 人格者でしょうに
人格者がそういうものを着てはいけない というふうに変な話をするんです
お金さえあれば 余裕があれば
もう高級なものを使っても どうってことないんですよ
でもそれにとらわれるなよと
それこそ命だと思うなよと
心は別なものですよ 本当の幸せっていうのは
物があっても幸せ なくても幸せ
だからお釈迦様の教典の中であるのは
やっぱり この 私たちは
お釈迦様はよく 激しく そういうのは批判的に言ってますけどね
ただ服を着ていない インドである宗教がありましてね
ジャイナ教というね 服は着ません
裸でいるんですよ　なんで裸でいるんですか？というと
何も物を持たない という主義なんです
でお釈迦様が聞くのは
あなた方はもう 全て裸でいるということでね
それで心が清らかになるんですかと
物が心を汚したんですか？ということなんです
ただ文化的でなくなってしまった
行儀が悪くなっただけじゃないかと
礼儀作法を守らなくなっただけでしょうと
でも その宗教の ジャイナ教の行者たちも
座るものと 何かいくつか道具を持っています
そうすると そのものに執着する
だから このものが悪いということは
私が悪いのは他人のせいだ ということなんですね
私がもう本当は悪くない
今 悪くなっているのは周りのせいだと
それは 仏教では成り立たない話なんですよ
学校のせいで 子供が勉強できなかったと言ったら
もともと その子供の心が悪いでしょうに
社会のせいで 周りのせいで私はこうなったんだと
よく人のせいにする もののせいにする
でも それは受け取ったのは自分でしょうに
人にいじめられても
それをどのように受け取るかということは
自分の能力次第でしょうに
で 気が弱くなって 絶望感に追われて 落ち込むか
それに適切に明るく対応するか
どちらか自分にできるでしょうに 判断することは
頭さえしっかり働かすんだったら
いつでもどんな問題も 乗り越える方法はあるんですよ
それはない人々が いつでももののせいに
社会のせいにする
執着の一つの側面だけ 説明してましたけど
またいろいろ 側面があります
執着があればあるほど 人は暗くなってしまうんですよ
すごく暗くなっちゃうんです
あれは自由を失うことと同じ
例えば すごい物惜しみ状態になってしまうと
やがて 友達に会うこともなくなってしまって
家から一歩も出ないようにもなる場合もあります
そこで 家に対してすごい執着がある場合は
どこか外国に旅行に行ったとしても なかなか楽しめないんですよ
家はどうだ 誰か入ったんでしょうかとかね
だからずっともう 例えば 4 日間
5 日間ぐらいしか外国に行かないんだけど
それでも 1 日 3回  2 3回ぐらい電話かけてみる
そこで家から出ても 携帯持って家に 1日 10回
15回  20回ぐらい 電話かけたりするとかね
そういうことで なかなか自由がなくなってしまって 暗くなるという
ものから離れられなくなってしまう
仏教でよく言うのは 餓鬼道という話があるんですね
餓鬼道というのは やっぱりこの
あまりにも執着しすぎると過ぎると
死んでも この世の中に ものに囚われてしまって
すごく悪い 不幸なところに生まれ変わってしまうんだと
という その次元は餓鬼道というんですね
で 次にこのモノに対することを喋りましたけど
次に執着っていうのは
大変な執着がありまして
自分の意見に対する執着
概念に対する執着 それまたすごい怖いものなんです
意見 概念 自分が勉強したもの
そういうものに対する執着が入ってしまうと
その人には かすかにも進歩がなくなっちゃうんです
ものすごく硬くなってしまって
傲慢になって 人の話も聞けない
ものすごい恐ろしいことになります
すごい仏教はもう大変
あれよりも 物に対する執着っていうのは
もう一旦ひどい目に遭ったらね
なくなりますからね 例えば
結婚 2度失敗した人が もうこりごりだという場合もあるでしょう
もうこりごりだと
だから そうやって ものにとらわれて ものにやられた場合も
その執着は 消える可能性はありますけど 簡単に
でも 思考に対する執着っていうのは 恐ろしいものなんですよ
人間の脳細胞の開発は そのまま止まってしまうんです
仏教の考え方は どんな概念にもとらわれるなよと
どんな概念にも 我々はそうじゃないんですね
自分が小さい時から いろんなことを知って
聞いて 勉強したりして
自分というものを作ってしまうんですね
それですごく硬くなって
私はこういうものだと
私は芸術家だと 私は音楽家だと
私はなになに家だと なになに とか何とか言ったりして
他のものは全く 聞こうと知ろうともしない
そこでよく いろいろ会議とかありますね
何かの問題があったら
どうですか？あなたはどう思いますか？あなたはどう思いますか？という
会議っていうのは みんなそれぞれの人が持っている知恵を出して
より良い決断というか
対策を作ることでしょう
ああいうのは 一つも役に立たないんですね
会議やっても 時間とお金の無駄
なぜかというと みんなが みんなの顔色を見て 何も言わない
そこで凶暴な人は 自分が思ったことを言い出しちゃったら
あなたどう思いますか？いや
あれ それ結構な意見だと思いますよと
それでは 話し合いにも会議にもならないんですよ
で なぜ自分の意見を言わないかと
言うと 二人とも悪いんですよ
凶暴な意見を言った人に対して
私は違うと思います と言ったら
その凶暴な人は ものすごく怒る
あなた何様だと思っているんでしょうか とかいう状態に怒るんですね
そうすると 言った人の立場がなくなっちゃうんですよ
クビになる可能性もあります
だから意見があっても言えない
なぜならば 受ける側があまりにも強情
あまりにも 自分の意見が正しいと思っているからなんです
そこでもう一つ 自分の意見を こそこそと言ったところで
他の人々の 反対の意見があって
自分の意見が潰れると
ものすごく嫌になっちゃうんですね
自分を潰したと 勘違いするんです
意見が潰されただけなんですけど
そこでプライドが傷ついちゃって
いわゆる批判は怖がるんです
反対意見を怖がるんです
反対意見を怖がるんだから
自分の意見があっても言わないで
何とか言ってうまくごまかす
だから言葉が曖昧
生き方が曖昧 思考が曖昧
だから 世界まるごとに曖昧
何をやっているか分からない
そこで 仏教に対して反論したとしても
一言で壊されるぐらいの バカバカらしい質問を出したり
質問ではなくて 反論出したりする
質問は別に どんな質問でも結構ですけど
例えば 執着によって人が人を殺したりもする
戦争したりもする 親が大変 苦労したりする
みんな過労になって 死んだりもする
大損もしたりする それなのに やっぱり執着は捨てるわけにいきません
執着したらダメですよと
とまた逆に言う どっちですか？と
世の中を見てないだけなんですね
だから なぜ我々は曖昧かということは
大体この思考 自分の思考にあまりにもとらわれすぎて
人間というのは 自分が思ったことを正しいと思うんですよ
母親が 自分が思ったことを 正しいと思って子供に喋る
子供は 自分が思ったことを正しいと思っているんですよ
そこでお互いに喧嘩になって
仲良く 楽しく 生きていられるのに
それは壊れてしまうんですよ
だから ほとんどの世の中の喧嘩っていうのは
食べ物を奪うための喧嘩じゃないんです
思考のぶつかりなんですよ
大体 現代社会で どこかの国がね
食べ物がなくて困っているんだと思ったら
それなりに助けてあげたりしますから 問題ないんですよ
例えば 北朝鮮が食糧がないんだとからといって
ただその理由で 韓国を責めることはしません
もし思考がぶつかっちゃったら
もうどうなるかわからない
自分の意見ぶつかっちゃったら
だって自分が正しいんだからね
たとえ国構え作っても 政治システムが無茶苦茶で
国が貧乏になっても 自分が思っている思考が正しいと よく言うこと
世の中にすごい 不幸や対立やら出てくるのは
自分の意見正しいと 宗教の間でも ものすごく恐ろしい争いやるでしょう
なぜかというと その各宗教が 自分の意見こそ正しいと思っているからなんです
でないと別に喧嘩する必要はないんです
それぞれ 単なる見方だけですよと
だから ものに対する執着の次に
自分の思考に対する執着っていうのはものすごい
恐ろしいことだと思った方がいいんです
例えば 科学者の方がこちらに来たとしましょう
で 私はもう科学っていうのは そんな大したことないと言ったら
その人は あなた何言うんですか？と
科学こそ万能ではないかということで
もう喧嘩になるんですね
それで私も自分が言ったことは 厳密に正しいと思ったならば
もう お互いにやり合っちゃうんですよ　それで終わらないで
永久的にその人の顔を見たくないんだ というところまで行っちゃうんですね
ただの概念なのに ただ思ったことなのに
だから楽な生き方っていうのは
何も そうやって頑固に思っていない方なんですよ
その場 その場で いろんな意見はできますから 頭の中で
それはその場の意見であって
また違う意見が入ったら
それはもう調整しますよと
例えば 会議なんかでは
一応 私が集めたデータによると
私はこういう結論に至りましたが
いろいろ調整いたしますので
反対意見やらいろんな意見を出してくださいと
それで全く反対意見だったところで
本当の人だったら それこそすごくありがたがるんですよ
あら 真っ向から反対意見が出たんだと
ということは 自分が見てない側面で 自分が扱っていないデータをその人が扱っているんだと
あ これは何なのかと 自分には開いていなかったドアでしたからね
それ自体をありがたがらないと
我々はそうじゃないんですよ
反対意見を言う人は みんな敵に回しちゃって
賛成派だけで 行動しようとする
それもまた どんどん成長がなくなってしまう
とにかく物に対する執着よりも恐ろしいのは 自分の意見に対する執着なんです
仏教的にものを見ると
人の意見は正しくないんですが
その人っていうのは 何かの経験を 何とかの角度で見て
そういう結論になっているぐらいのことで
だから その人については
それは正しい意見だと
例えば 昔の人々は 地球は平らだと思っていたでしょう
今はそれは間違っているんだと言うんだけど
私はそうは言いたくないんですよ
当時の人間が 自分住んでいる世界を見て
これは平らですよと だから入ったデータを見て
それで 結論を出したんですね
それで 現代人が自分に入るデータによって
これ平らなものではないと
だから昔の人間が 原始時代で 自然を見たら
やっぱり 全部 神様が作ったんだと
なぜかと考えてみたら
自分がいて 自分の母親がいて
母親の母親がいて その母親の母親がいて
それで狂っちゃうんですね
やっぱり簡単便利なのは
まず誰かが作ると それから生まれていくのはもう簡単ですよ
それは その人々に入ったデータによって 至った結論なんですね
我々から考えちゃうと
だから 人類はみんな 同じ女の人から生まれたんですかと
そこはその人たち 知らなかったんですよ
また他の国もあるんだと
どうにかこうにかして ぐずぐずとくだらんことを考えてしまうと
そういう風にもう 初めの人がいて
女がいて そこからみんなで生まれていったと言っただけ
だから そういうのは間違いでも正しいでもなく
その人々に入ったデータによって 至った結論なんですよ
お釈迦様がその説明すると
データは認めるんですね
結論は認めないんですよ
だから一番良いのは そうやって頑固と結論に至らないことなんです
これ 業の説明する経典で
ある経典がございます
中部経典なんですが
業 カルマ kamma のことを説明すると こう言うんですよ
ある修行者が出家して
厳密に 修行して超能力を得られるんだと
超越した能力を得られるんだと
得られて 彼にはいくらか物事を見られる能力つくんだと
ついたところで ある人のことを観察すると
そこで その人が何者かで見たら
殺生するは 嘘をつくは よこしまな行為をするとかね
そうやって悪事を犯している
そこで その人が死ぬ
死んだらどこに生まれ変わったかと 自分の能力で見たら
悪いところに 不幸なところに 生まれ変わっているのは見られる
見られると 彼が結論を出す
やっぱり 悪事を犯したら 不幸になるんだよと
それこそ事実だと もし人が違うことを言うならば
それは間違いだと と説法するんだと
また もう一人の行者が同じく修行して
超越した能力を得て またある人を観察するんだと
観察したら その人は殺生もしないし
盗みも働かないし 何も悪事をしない
すごい善行為をしている
やがてその人は死ぬ
死んだところで どこに生まれ変わったかと見ると
経典は長いんだから その人は天国にいるのを見つかるとかって
そこは ちょっと省いて
また ある行者がそうやって人を見る
悪事を犯している人を見る
人を見たら その人死んだところで どこに生まれ変わったかと見る
見ると なんとこの人 天国に生まれ変わっているんだ
自分が その人が生きていた時
どんなことをやったかと 見たところで
悪事を犯してたんですよ
殺生やら 盗みやら なんだかんだ 十悪ありますから
で 死んで生まれ変わった
どこに生まれ変わったかというと
天国にいるんではないかと
大変 幸福になってしまう
そこで その行者がこう決めるんだそうです
やっぱり 悪事を犯しても
善行為してもね 大した意味がないと
いわゆる悪行為には悪結果
悪い結果がないんだと
なぜならば 私は何々さんを観察したところで
その人が今 天国に生まれ変わっているのは
私は見たんだから それは事実ですよ
言って行為を否定する
また一人の行者が そうやってある人を観察しちゃうと
善行為を行っている人がいて
その人が死んで どこに生まれ変わったかを見ちゃうと
地獄に落ちているのが見られるんですね
それで その人もやっぱり あれほど善行為しても
死んでから地獄に落ちてるんだから
やっぱり善行為には結果がないんだと決めてしまう
そこで お釈迦様はそういう例を全部並べて こう言うんですよ
その行者が観察したのも認める
観察してた人が善行為をやっていたんだと
それで その善行をやった人が 死んでから地獄に行ったっていうことを
私はそれを事実だから認めますと
でもその行者の言い方はね
結論は認めませんと で
一番はっきりわかるのは
例えば 良いことをした人が地獄に落ちると
お釈迦様は良いことをしたことを認めるんだと
地獄に落ちたことを認めるんだと
でも結論は認めませんと
なぜならば 彼らの観察方法は間違っているんだと
ですから ちゃんと順番で 原因ー結果の順番で きちんと観察するべきですよと
善行為をした人も 例えば死んでから地獄に落ちたならば
その人は その善行為をする以前に
悪行為を犯したことがあるかもしれません
あるいは善行為をして
その後で 死ぬちょっと前でも 心が汚れたかもしれませんと
そちらは観察していないんだと
ですから このデータは認めるんだけど
いい加減にまとめて結論を出すことは 否定してしまうんですね
そこら辺を説明すると 難しくなりますね
だから話は他の方向へ持っていきますけど
私たちは自分の意見に しがみつくことは危険です
なぜならば 自分がすべて知っているわけじゃないんです
すべてをすべての尺度で見たわけじゃないんです
たまたま ちょっと一つだけ 見ただけ
例えば こちらで来て ある人が喧嘩したとする
それで私たちは 何々さんがとんでもない 行儀の悪い 怒りっぽい悪人だと決めつけちゃうと
その結論が間違っている
何々さんが この勉強会に来て喧嘩したんだよ という事実は正しいんです
だから我々言うべきなのは
この勉強会に来た時だけ
勉強会に来た時 その人の生き方が良くなかったと
私たちのやり方はそうじゃない
その人は全体的に否定する
あいつは悪人だと あの結論がまるっきり間違ってるんですよ
その人は小さい時 どんな性格でしたか？学校でどんな性格でしたか？家庭でどんな人ですか
会社でどんな人で　わかるもんですかね
何一つも調べてないんです
そこである人が すごく良いことをやろうと
立派に行動しようと 有名になって頑張ろうとすると
そんなこと今さら言ったっても
この人は 23 歳で どこかでなんとかして 警察で取り調べられたことがあるんだと
故に悪人だと それ言えますかね そんなことは
例えば 二十歳頃
いろいろ麻薬もやってみたりとかね
いろいろ女性がいるところに行って遊んだりとかね
そこで捕まったりとかね
したことがあったかもしれませんけど
それからはどんどん良い人間になって
立派な人間に後でなりえないんですかね
なることは　できますよ
だから人間の思考というのはそうじゃなくて
自分 何かいい ただ 例えば立派な人がいる
その人は
潰したいという気持ちが生まれてくる
その先に感情が出てきて
先に答えが 目的が出てきて
その目的を達するために 必要なポイントだけ取る
他のポイントを消す そういうことだから　どんな人間でも
だから自分の意見にとらわれることは 一番危険なんです
ですから 人間 いろいろ意見があるでしょ
くだらんというと
これは何一つも意見というのは
知識的に正しい意見には 残念ながらならないんですよ
それぞれ自分の感情で語る
例えば 現代の若者の生き方が良くないという意見を持ってる人だったら
その人を調べるデータは すべて若者の間違いだけ取ってきて見せて
見てごらんなさいと 現代の若者の立派なところは全然 無視と
ある政治家を潰したければ
その人のやった 悪いことだけ調べてそれを出す
でも人間というのは 純粋に悪いことだけするわけじゃないでしょう
だったら そういうふうな偉い人にならないでしょうに
純粋に良いこともできるわけじゃないでしょうに
それはすごく面白いのは
アメリカの政治の世界で
もう大統領選挙なんか出たら
一生懸命 反対側が何を調べるかというと
生まれた瞬間から その瞬間までの全部 調べて
すべて どこかでもないか
何かおかしいことをしたことがないかと
大体 誰かの 女性の体を触って もう事件になったこと
それだけでもいいんですよ
それで この女性に殴られちゃって 会社クビになったと
今は大金持ちで 大統領選挙に出ているから あれ出すんですね
いかにくだらなくて アホかというと
英語を読めるならば アメリカの新聞もざんざん出ますから
インターネットで読んでみてください
これは世界を支配している立派な人間ですかと
新聞なんか見ると 品のないこと
やっぱり たとえアメリカにしろ
他の国にしろ やっぱり人間は人間だから
ろくなことじゃないんですよ
大したことないんですよ
だから自分の出したい意見だけ言うために何か
データ集めていったりする
そういうことですから
我々はそこら辺 気を付けると かなり無執着の生き方ができるんですよ
物はそんなに問題じゃないんですよ
いくら欲しくて 欲しくて
例えば 4年間  5年間 お金貯めて 何かを買ったりしたとしても
それは壊れちゃったら しょうがないやと諦めますからね
物に対する執着っていうのは それほど問題じゃないんですよ
例えば 10年ローンで車買ったりする
スピード出したところで もう潰れてしまったと
ああ 悔しいなというぐらいで
もう終わっちゃいますよ
でも 意見に対する執着は そんな生易しいものじゃないんです
そういうことだから 自分の意見に対する執着ということは 大変 気をつけてください
意見 自体もおかしいんですよ
それは自分の都合によって 自分が作るものであって
事実を語っているわけじゃないんです
で  3番目の恐ろしい執着っていうのは
自分に対する執着ということでね
生きていきたいと 死にたくはないんだと
自分がいるんだという
それは基本的なところで
どうもこの ものを見たり聞いたり
喋ったり考えたりすると
なんか自分がいるんだという
錯覚は必ず生まれるんです
何か目を開けて見たら
私が見たと 耳に音が入ったら私が聞いたと
で 味わった時も 日本語ではちょっと言いにくいんだけど
私には美味しかったと
足が痛いんだったら 私の足が痛いんですと
そういうふうに思うんだから
この私がどこにいるんですかね
私が見たと言葉で言うんだけど
その見た私がどこにいるんですかね
見るということは 科学的にはっきりしていますからね
目を通して 光の反射したデータが
脳細胞に入って 電気信号を起こして
脳細胞の中で ちょっと電気信号を起こすだけでしょ
それも 脳の構成によって何を見るかどうかは わからないんですね
だから 我々は本当にあるものは 見てないんですよ
幻覚なんです 頭の中で見ているのは
幻覚だから 例えば ある絵は私が綺麗と思ってしまうし
ある人は綺麗じゃないと思っちゃうしね
事実を見るんだったら みんな同じ意見を言うでしょ
だからその 頭の中で幻覚を作っちゃうんですね
だから見るっていうことは
それぐらいのこと そちらに私がいるわけではないんです
味わう時でも同じことで
私の足というと 私の手
私の首 私の心臓 そうやって全部私のであって
私はどこですかね
体のいたるものを取ってみたら これは 私の であって 私 ではありませんでしょ
髪の毛を見たって 私の髪の毛であって
髪の毛が私ではありません
目は私の目であって 目が私ではありませんでしょうに
それで 意見についても
これは 私の意見であって
意見が私ではありませんでしょ
悲しみについても
これは私の悲しみであって
悲しみが私ではありませんね
楽しみの場合も 同じことなんですね
私が楽しいのであって
楽しみが私ではありません
この私が どこにいるんですかね
とにかく それは化け物なんですよ
だから逃げる これじゃない
別ですよ これじゃないですよ
時々 人が私の手を殴ったら
私はすぐに なんで私を殴るんですか？と反論するでしょ
そうするとその人が 私は手を殴ったんだけど
あなたを殴ったことないんですよ と言ったら
いえ これ私の手ですよと 言っちゃうでしょう
だから初めは 手は私でしたけど
これはちょっと話して
いや 逃げるんですよ 私が
手が私のもの
そこで聞けば その私がどこにいるんですかと
見つからないんです どこまででも逃げる
化け物ですからね で そういうものだから
我々は ずっと 私がいるという前提で生きているんですね
それは一番 取りにくい執着なんです
それも ものすごい不幸を作ってくれるんですよ
人が手を殴ったって 怒る必要ないでしょ
これ 私の手だから怒るんであって
でなきゃ怒らないでしょうに
人が隣の家に泥棒が入ったって
私は平気でいるんですよ
悪口も言うんですね ろくに鍵もかけないんだから
もう良いことだと そんなことは
そこまで言うんですよ
で 私の家に泥棒が入っちゃったら
もう すごく怒って 警察に文句言うんですよ
いい加減で 税金で食べてるだけで
ちゃんと泥棒も捕まえてこないと
誰にでも悪口　なぜかというと
私の家だからなんです
人が人を殺したと聞いたとしても
全然 平気な顔してるんですよ
ああそうというだけで終わり
人が自分の誰かを殺しちゃったら
そうはうまくいかないんですね
私の息子を殺しちゃったんだよと
だから 一生憎むんだよ ということになってしまうんです
だから大変なものなんです
この私って その一言が
それに執着しているんだから
私たちは 全ての執着を作るんです
私が 幸せになりたいんだから結婚するんだと
私が 幸せになりたいんだから勉強する
私は 幸せになりたいんだから
もう何々の偉くなるんだとか
そこで 体を分解してみて
心を分解してみたら もうただそれぞれ機能のみであって
そこに私がないとわかったら
一番取りにくい執着が 消えてしまうんですね
それはもう悟りの世界で 私がという概念消えたら
もう悟ってるんですね
問題はなし
そういうふうに 執着といっても
こういうふうに３つに分けて 考えた方がよろしいと思います
皆様方は あまり気になるのは
この 1番目ですね 物に対する執着
どうってことない そんなものは　あってもなくてもどうでもいいんですよ
いっぱい財産があっても 執着なしに生きていられるんです
私はそういう人々を見てきたこともありますけど
かなり恵まれていて 無いということは全くない状態で生きているんだけど
全く 軽々とした心で すごく無執着の心でいられる
大体この過去生で この自我なしに
執着なしに 人にものを施したり
すごくいいことをした人々が 豊かになって生まれ変わりますよ
生まれ変わっても
金が勝手に入るんであって
自分で儲かろうという気持ちもない
何やっても遊びでやるんであって
やっぱりまた金が舞い込んでくる
だからって執着するかというと執着もしない
面白くもないんですよ
勝手に来るんだから そういう人もいますよ
実際に私が知っている人々もいますからね
バブルになろうが何になろうが
もうその人には関係ないんです
金入る道が変わるだけで
こういう方向で金入っていて
そこでバブルで閉ざされたら
こちらから入り込んでくるという
だから本人はやっぱり過去の習慣
癖がついているんだから
それでも全然 物に囚われない
すごい気楽に気持ちよく
すごく明るく生きていられる
明るさは消えちゃうんです 執着が出てきて
だから皆さんはよく興味ある話はっていうのは
この物に対する執着なんですけど
それは そんなに大げさな問題じゃないんです
もうちょっと物事を考えれば
すぐそこは なくりますけど
じゃあ それからこの 1番目の執着に対して
我々はどうすればいいかと
そこら辺だけ説明します
例えば 子供が生まれたら
これ私の子供だ と思ってしまうと 執着が生まれてくる
これ 私の子供じゃないんです
私も もともとないんだから
それはもう 限りない輪廻転生の中の 一人の生命が 自分の家に来ただけのことなんです
それでせっかく来た 自分の家を選んだ人だ
お客さんだから 一生懸命やってあげる分はやってあげる
いくらやってあげたっても
その人は全く独立している別な人だと
自分には その人を医者にしてやるぞとかね
あるいはエンジニアにしてあげるぞとかね
そこまで決めることは ちょっと失礼ですよ
結婚相手も決めてやるぞとかね
親が反対だから あなた結婚するなよとかね
そこまで行っちゃうと 出てくるのは苦しみだけ
生きることは いかに楽しく楽に生きていられるかを 忘れているんですね
みんな　高価なカバンを買っても
世の中みんな言ってるんだから 買っただけですよ というぐらいでね
これは そろそろ どんどんボロボロになるんだと
そんなもんだと 世の中っていうのは
家を造っても これは作ったその日からね
古くなっていくんだと
これくらい年取っちゃうと
これも古くなっちゃうんだと
その前に竜巻やら台風やらいろいろね
自然災害ありますから
地震やら火事やらね そういうもので消えるかもしれませんと
たとえ自分が作ったばっかしの家
火事になってなくなったと
そうすると 30年のローンだけ残っちゃうでしょうに
それで執着あると えらい苦しいんですよ
執着がないと まあまあ
大したことない そんなことはもうありえることだと
ありえることだと これから頑張ればいいんじゃないかと
大体 この短く考えればね
長く考えないで 今 どうすればいいかと
家が火事になったら 今 どうするべきかというと
やっぱり 逃げることとか 何か取れるものがあるんだったら
それ取るぐらいのことでしょう
それから 次にどうすればいいかと
それだけ考えちゃうと 結構 明るく生きていられます
人間 もともと考える能力がないにも関わらず
えらい 20年計画で 40年
100年計画で考えるんですよ
私は言うのは 1分計画で考える能力をつけてくださいと
もう考える能力はないんだと
勝手だと 思考自体は当てにならないんだと
大体 今 どうすれば良いのか というぐらいでいいんですよ
人生は 明日 明後日 明明後日
100年後になっちゃうと
もう何も考えることできないんです
妄想することしか ですから
この ものに対する執着を消したければ
今どうすればというぐらいの 短い範囲で物事を考える
それは仏教の修行になってくると
今の瞬間というものを見られると
すべての真理はわかるんだと
すべての執着が消えるんだと
だから仏教の瞬間という真理があるでしょうに
なぜ人間に煩悩があるかというと
これは 100年計画で考えるからでしょ
時々 会社を作ったら これは自分だけじゃなくて
孫も継いでほしいと 息子もその会社を継いで
それから孫も継いでほしいと
執着の恐ろしさといえば
そこで その会社に次に来るバカどもの孫も
やっぱりこのおじいさんが作った会社だから
3代目だからと で  4代目までやって欲しがるんですね
100年計画じゃないんですよ
そういうのはもう すごい苦しみだけ作る
束縛される 孫にはものすごい違う才能があっても しょうがないんですよ
孫にはものすごい 抜群の科学者になる能力があるとしましょう
でも おじいさんが自動車の修理工場を作ってやっているんだと
これかなり儲かってはいるんだと
それで そこを守らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
科学者を辞めて なることできない
小さい時から叩き込むんだからね
お前はこの会社の跡継ぎですよ
そうすると自分の自由を失ったんだから
その孫であろうが ひ孫であろうが
だいたい自由な時間はいい加減で
わがままで やりたい放題なことをやる
だってもう安定しているんだから
自分の将来は また面白くないしね
そういう人が入ってきたら
その会社も潰れる
やってきた計画もそれで壊れてしまうと
そういうことになりますから
あまり長い時間に計画を立ててはいけません
すべて瞬間で変化するんだから
できれば瞬間だけで見れば もう悟ることさえもできるんですよ
だから時間が短くなればなるほど
私たちは より正しい生き方をするんです
今 どうすればいいかと
今日 1日どうすればいいかと思ったら
より正しい生き方ができるんですよ
より楽なんです 今日は 1時間に絞って
1 分に絞っちゃうと もっと真理に近い生き方ができちゃうんですよ
それは瞬間に絞っちゃうと
真理はわかってしまって
悟りにまで至るんですね
だから執着をなくす方法として言えるのは
そうやって思考を短く
時間として短くすることなんです
例えば 今 体の調子が悪いと思ったら
私は病気だ 私の体は調子が悪いんだと
時間制限なしに言っちゃうでしょう
そこで理解する人々も 時間制限なしに思っちゃうんですね
そこがおかしいんです
時々 私も体の調子が悪い時
時々 ちょっと言ったりする場合
それは遊びで言うんだけど
言う必要ないんだけど
ちょっと今日は体の調子が悪い
私は今日はとか 今はとかね
はっきりと時間制限 言って言うんだけど
例えば 朝からもう元気でいて
もう 3時半になってくると
なんか調子が なんか嫌に 調子が悪くなったんですよと言っちゃうと
時間制限ちゃんとあるんですよ
今の時間からだと でも聞いてる方がそうじゃない
私は永久的に 体の調子が悪いと言って
一生懸命 親切に考えて
私の体に悪いことばっかり 持ってくるんです
私も困るんで これは気持ちはわかるし
これは一生懸命 親切に考えて持ってくるんだけど
これは 私には本当のところは要りませんという
もう こちらまで困る状態になっちゃうんですね
だからそれは冗談で わかりやすくするために言ったんだけど
今日は頭が痛いということは
永久的に頭が痛いわけじゃないんです
だから物事はちゃんと 時間制限の中で 考えたり行動したり
した方が一番 真理に近いと思います
4時ぐらいで 終了してもいいんですかね
じゃあ あとちょっと５分ございまして
私は一つ ものすごく長い経典を持ってきたんです
で これ読み上げをしても
15分以上はかかります
その経典にあるストーリーだけ説明します
お釈迦様は舎衛城（コーサラ国の首都）に住んでいた時
ある在家の方に一人息子がいたんだと
ものすごいかわいい息子がいて
その息子が死んでしまったと
息子が死んだ時は 彼が悲しくて仕事はできなくなっちゃったと
ご飯も食べられなくなったと
彼が火葬場に行って 私の一人息子はどこに行ったんでしょうか
なんで死んでしまったのだろうとかね
毎日泣くんだと そこで彼がお釈迦様に会うんですよ
お釈迦様に会ったら お釈迦様がその人にこう言うんですね
あなた なんだか自分でないようだと
こちらにいても いないようだと
調子が悪いんだと 体もおかしいんだと
なんかいてもボーっとしているんだからね
こちらに居ても なんかこちらにいないような感じですよと
何でしょうか と聞いたら
もう何をおっしゃるんですかと
Kiñhi me, bhante, indriyānaṁ nāññathattaṁ bhavissati
私はそんな調子になるのは不思議じゃないんだと
私にいた一人息子が もう死んでしまったんだ
だから私はもうずっと こちら来るまではね
何日間も毎日 火葬場に行って
もう泣いていたんだと
やっとちょっと落ち着いて お寺でお釈迦様に会ったんですけども
それでお釈迦様は あ それはその通りです
その通りですよ 好きなものはね
好きなものっていうのは
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみしか作ってくれないんだよと
何のことなく 単純なことをおっしゃったんですよ
この人はもう 人が狂ったような状態でしょうね
その通りですよ この好きなものっていうのは
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみしか作ってくれないんだと
事実はおっしゃったんだけど
その人が
こう言うんですよ　そんなことはありえないよと
お釈迦様 そんなことはありえないんだと
好きなものがあってこそ
人間に喜びも楽しみも 幸福感も生まれるのではないか
と言って お釈迦様に反論しちゃったんです
反論して それで説法にならないんだからね
お互いに喧嘩しても
で 彼が帰っちゃうんです
帰っていくと その道で ろくでもない人間のグループがいたんですよ
仕事もしないで ものすごくだらしない
もう賭け事ばっかりやったり
酒飲んで 賭け事ばっかりやって
そういう ろくでもない人間のグループがいたんです
そちらはやることを 仕事もしないんだからね
人のお金でも盗んで 賭け事にして
それで賭けたりして また遊んだりするだけのことだからね
暇があるんですよ それでいたら
この在家の人が通っていると
その人に あなた どこに行ってきたんですかと
言ったら 彼がお釈迦様に会って帰ったんです
お釈迦様って何をいう人ですかねと言ったら
お釈迦様がね この好きなものが
憂い 悲しみ 苦しみの元だと言ったんだと
私はそれを反対しましたと
好きなものがあれば人間は幸せでしょう
と言ったら その人々は それはしっかりその通りですよと
あなたは正しいんだと
人間が好きなことをやっていけば
いかに楽しいかと それが事実だと言って
あのバラモン人を褒めたんです
バラモン人じゃない
この普通の在家の人
あなたは正しいんだと
そこで 仏教の信者さんだから
この人 すごく恥ずかしくなったんですよ
自分の意見が ろくでもない
仕事もしない 賭け事やら悪いことばっかりしてる
人の意見とぴったし合うんですね
偉大なる お釈迦様の意見とは合わないんですよ
それですごく恥ずかしくなっちゃったんです
でも その結論は出てこなかったんですよ
簡単なことで そこで その話がどんどん広がっていってしまって
コーサラ王様にその話が届いてしまったんですね
コーサラ王様も認めた
やっぱり楽しいものは 楽しみを作ってくれるんだという態度で
そこでお妃がいるんです
マッリカー(Mallikā)夫人という マッリカーさんは悟りを開いていて
お釈迦様の大変 大事な信者さんなんですが
彼女に あなたどう思いますか？
お釈迦様はなにか おかしいことをおっしゃっているのではないか と言ったら
マッリカー夫人が いや これがお釈迦様がおっしゃったならばね
それはその通りですよと　そうは言っても
マッリカー夫人でも これ説明できないんですよ
でも彼女が預流果に悟っていたんだから
いつでも お釈迦様の意見はその通りです という立場なんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
私に分からなくても 間違いなはずがない という立場なんです
と言ったら 王様がもうからかっちゃって
お前ね なんだかね お釈迦様がおっしゃったら正しいというだけで
何もわかってないでしょうと
いい加減にしなさいと
言われたマッリカー夫人も 負けてはいられませんから
で こそこそとお釈迦様の方に人を送ったんですよ
送って このことをお釈迦様に報告して
お釈迦様に説明聞きなさいよと
でお釈迦様は この人々はあまりにも頭が悪いんだから
厳密な説明しないで 簡単ないろいろストーリーを言うんですよ
昔 この同じ 舎衛城の町で お釈迦様
ある女がいて その女のお母さんが死んじゃったんだと
死んじゃったところで
この娘さんが 頭が狂っちゃって
頭が狂ってしまったと
狂ってしまって
家を出て いろんな道路をあっちこっち 歩き回るようになったんだと
道から道へ こっちあっち行っていて
頭狂ってるんだから
何をいったかというと 私のお母さん見た？ とお母さん捜しに行ったんだそうです
この娘さんが もしかすると子供かもしれません
この経典でわかりませんけど
子供には時々 そういうこともありますからね
死んだっていうことで わからなくなっちゃって
お母さんどこ？お母さんどこ？とかね
じっと待ってるとか あるいは探しに行くとかね
頭が狂っちゃった とにかく
だから 好きなものから ろくな結果が出てこないんだと
その娘さんが お母さんのことを大好きで
お母さん死んじゃったと
だから頭狂っちゃったんだと
そうやって いろいろ例を出すんですね
そこでもう一つストーリーがありまして
ある女の人が お嫁に出されてしまったんですね
お嫁に出されるところへ
その家の人々が このお嫁さんをあまり気に入らなくて
他の人にあげたがってしまうんですね
あなたに他の誰かを話しあってあげましょうと
で 家から出そうとするんです
でも この女の人が それはあんまり好きじゃないんですね
それで自分の旦那に言ったんですよ
親戚が 私をこの家から外へ出して
他の誰かのとこにあげたがってるんだと
私はどこにも行きたくないのです
その人は何をしたんですかというと
この人もおそらく 弱い人でしたでしょうね
両親が言うことが怖くて
親戚が言うことが怖くて
だから この人が何か刃物を持ってきて
その女を刺して殺しちゃったそうです
殺して自分も自殺しちゃったんだと
二人は別れたくないんです
でも この家の関係で この女の人は他の家に出してしまって
それで離婚になりますから
自分の息子に もっと他のお嫁さんをもらえるんだからね
それでこの二人がもうどうしても
親戚たちに両親に もう別れさせられるでしょうに
それは嫌で 女の人を殺して 自分も死んでしまったと
だから好きなことっていうのは
そうやって 大変な結果を作ってしまいますよと
で そこでマッリカー夫人が その話を お釈迦様の説法を聞いて
で しっかりして 王様のところに行って
王様は子供たちがいろいろ いるんですね
例えば ヴァーサバー・カッティヤー(Vāsabhā khattiyā)という
この大変 綺麗な娘さんがいたんですよ
で 王様がね ヴァーサバー・カッティヤーという娘さんのことをどう思いますか？と
好きですか？と 大好きですよと
大好きですよと ああそう
もし ヴァーサバー・カッティヤーがね
変な病気にかかったりして
おかしくなったりしちゃうと
あなた気持ちいいんですか？と
と言ったら とんでもないんだと
とんでもないな そんなことは 思っただけでも嫌ですよ
と言ったら だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
ヴァーサバー・カッティヤーという娘のことを あなた好きだから
その彼女がちょっと何か病気になったら あなたがおかしくなるんだと
だから苦しみが生まれるんだと
どんどん いろいろ人のことを聞いて
最後に あなた私のこと好きですか？と
そしたら コーサラ王様のお気に入りなんですよ
第1番目に マッリカーさんが 頭よろしいし
言ったら 君のことをすごい大好きですよ
もし私が病気になって倒れたり
早く死んじゃったりしちゃうと
あなたは楽しいですか？と言ったら
楽しいどころか もう嫌で 狂ってしまうかもしれませんよ
だから 好きなものが苦しみを作ってくるんだと
で 最後に王様は自分のことを好きですか
と いちいち そうやって質問するんですね
あなたは 国のこと好きですか
この国は 私は大好きです
じゃあ この国が 誰かに盗られたり 無くなったりしたら
あなたはどうなるんですかね
それでは 並みならぬ悲しみを味わうでしょう
だから 好きなものは悲しみを作ってくるんだと
あなたは自分の財産好きですか　財産 好きです
財産なくなったんたらどうなるんですか？　そうしたらすごいショックを受けるでしょうと
ということで 延々と言ったら
もうコーサラ王様は やっぱりさすが お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは正しいんだ
ということで お釈迦様の意見が通ります
そこでお釈迦様が礼をするんですね
それよりか この経典の中で
この厳密にポイントは そこまで言う必要ないんだけど
あの在家の人が 1週間ぐらい 飲まず食わず仕事もしないで
なぜ苦しかったかというと
子供に対してすごい愛着
執着あったからなんです
だから 例えば嫌な人が死んじゃったら
あんな苦しみが生まれないでしょう
だから人間 好きなものばっかり集めたがるんだけど
その集まる好きなものっていうのは ちょっとしたことで壊れちゃいますよ
すべて壊れますからね
だから 必ず苦しみがあって
お母さん 大好きですよと言うと
お父さん 大好きですよと言って 喜んでいたとしても
そのお母さん お父さん 必ず死ぬんですよ
そうすると 好きな分だけ
それより何倍も 苦しまなくちゃいけないんですよ
子供が生まれると ああ
もう大好きですよと 目に入れても痛くはないんですよ
と言うんだけど その目に入れても痛くない時
その子供に何かあったらどうなるんですかね
だから ものすごい苦しみが生まれてくるんですよ
ですから 執着は苦しみの元なんです
作ってくれる楽しみっていうのは ほんのわずかなんですよ
面白くて 外車でも買っても
それを守る苦しみは 大変なんですよ
気をつけて 気をつけて
かすり傷でもつけないようにとかね
でも ちょっとしたことで 全部潰れちゃったら
ものすごい苦しみが生まれる
特に高級車の場合は かなりそう　盗まれてしまいますでしょうね
安い車だったら 誰も持っていかないんですけど
そうすると ものすごいショックを受けちゃうんですね
愛着があればあるほど ショックは受ける
諦めちゃったらね　諦めるということは
ただ諦めて 馬鹿みたいにいるんじゃなくて
諦め　ということになったら
それを調べることができますよ 元気で
愛着ばっかりやっちゃうと
調べることも なくなったものを取り戻すことさえも できなくなっちゃうんですね
だから子供に対しても
子供は育てるんであって
育てるだけのことだったら
病気になっても すごい冷静を保って どうすればいいかということを わかるんですよ
はー 私の大事な子供だと思ったら 冷静を失ってしまうんです
ですから 病気になった子供に するべき治療さえも できなくなってしまうんですね
執着がないと 冷静さが出てくる
それでもって みんな守られます
自分の子供が遊び始めた時
コソコソと歩き始めた時
何かつかまったり 何かやったりして
体に火でもついちゃったら
すぐ冷静さを失ってしまうんですよ
そうすると もうほんのちょっとの 損害で終わることが
すごく大きくなってしまうんですね
自分の家でちょっと火が出たとしても
すごく 冷静さっていうのがあれば
じゃあ こういう風に消せばいいでしょうと
愛着ある人にとっては 大変だ
どうしよう どうしようと
もう119番も忘れちゃうんですね
家に消火器あっても もう見つからないんで
その時に限って 感情が出てくるんですね
だから いかなる場合でも
その愛着の感情が出ないように 冷静にいれば
何の問題もないんですよ
すごく 人生っていうのは楽しくはなります
生きることも楽しくなります
じゃ 話はそこら辺で 終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます